You all know that I don't subscribe to the
polling conspiracy theories that you can't
trust polls that polling is fake.
That polling is somebody in an office making
up numbers that the polls only call old people
on landlines.
I don't subscribe to any of those conspiracy
theories because they're bogus.
And we know that they're bogus by looking
at methodology.
Well done polling, especially when you average
a bunch of good polls.
You get a really good sense of where races
look at 2016.
Hillary was leading the national polls by
3.2.
She won by 2.1.
That's within the margin of error that the
polls were correct nationally in 2016.
Now, something really dishonest was done by
CNN last week with a poll that they did.
And I want to call it out.
CNN announced that in battleground states,
Trump is winning 52 to 45.
Now, as a savvy news consumer, you should
immediately say, what?
What does that mean?
Fifty two to forty five across battleground
states.
Are you saying that you added up all of the
different people in those states and in total,
Trump is winning by seven?
Do you mean that his average lead in each
state is seven?
Are you waiting those results for the populations
of the.
What does that mean?
Because states are different populations,
different electoral vote values?
Well, if you look at page nine of the CNN
poll, the methodology page actually says for
the subset of five hundred and eighty three
adults living in the 15 battleground states,
there is a margin of error of 5.3 percentage
points.
So, first of all, you've got to sample that
across 15 different battleground states is
only five hundred and eighty three people
total.
Now, that could be thirty eight people for
state.
Not a good sample size.
Some states maybe had more of that sample
and some less because of their population
and the margin of error is 5.3.
So this could be essentially a tie or Trump
could be leading by 12.
This tells us very little.
But the most important thing is that this
poll, when it says Trump's winning in these
15 states by seven, it doesn't tell us how
far ahead Trump or Biden are in any particular
state.
What I mean is Georgia's included in these
15 states.
Well, Trump's winning by Georgia by at around
8:00 right now, 7 or 8, is Georgia even really
a battleground?
Georgia has 16 electoral votes.
It's not really in play for Joe Biden.
Why is it included and how is it skewing these
results?
Some other states that are included are actual
battleground states like, for example, Nevada.
It's actually sort of close.
Biden is plus four.
But Nevada only has six electoral votes.
So how are you waiting these different states?
And what does it mean that Trump is winning
by seven across the states?
This poll doesn't have very useful information.
And unfortunately, it was picked up on by
a bunch of right wing media and even some
left wing media.
And it is being spread like some kind of gospel.
So let's do something that makes more sense.
Let's look at each state one by one and then
total up the electoral vote.
So when you actually break this down, Joe
Biden is winning Arizona, Colorado, Florida,
Maine, Michigan, Minnesota, Nevada, New Hampshire,
New Mexico, Pennsylvania, Virginia, Wisconsin.
And then on the other hand, Donald Trump is
winning in Georgia.
Donald Trump is winning in North Carolina.
In Ohio, the point is, when you add up the
electoral votes in these supposed battleground
states, regardless of the combined population,
as of right now, Joe Biden would get close
to 75 percent of the electoral votes from
these 15 battleground states.
Now, I want to be really clear.
This is just a snapshot.
It's a moment in time.
This is not about Biden's got this.
It's not about staying home in November.
It's not about Biden's going to win.
The point is, when I simply say Trump's winning
by seven in these 15 battleground states,
you then look at each state, you see, wait
a second, Biden's winning most of the states
and most of the electoral votes right now.
So polling is valuable in two ways.
And this isn't either of them.
Polling is valuable to be able to say what
is one state look like or polling is valuable
to say, what is the national popular vote
looking like, giving us what seems to be a
blended popular vote for fifteen states where
you call them battlegrounds.
But some, like Georgia, are not considered
battleground states.
It is deceptive.
It tells us nothing.
And it actually fuels uncritical reporting
from left, right and center media outlets.
That only confuses people even more.
Let's not fall for it.
That's why it's important to understand what
was done here.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Lastly, my personal Instagram David Pakman.
I took apart a whole watermelon yesterday,
posted it to my Instagram and people are losing
their minds.
David, that's not how you break down a watermelon.
David You using the wrong kind of knife?
David Your hair looks stupid.
David I didn't know you were left handed.
That's really better of you.
Check out the watermelon video on my Instagram.